supongamos que tenemos la función ye
igual al seno elevado al cubo de x
cuadrada el seno elevado al cubo de x
cuadrada y claro bueno esto también
podemos escribir lo común el seno de x
cuadrada todo esto elevado al cubo y
esta vez queremos encontrar cuál es la
derivada de esto con respecto a x que
claro también podemos escribirla
como de prima bueno podemos encontrar la
de varias formas aquí tenemos una
expresión sencilla elevada a la tercera
potencia si vemos desde afuera de esta
expresión veremos que tenemos algo aquí
elevado a la tercera potencia así que
una forma de abordarlo es usar la regla
de la cadena y por lo tanto al aplicar
la regla de la cadena vamos encontrar la
derivada de lo de adentro con respecto a
lo de afuera o dicho de otra manera la
derivada de algo que está elevado a la
tercera potencia con respecto a ese algo
entonces me quedara
tres veces es algo elevado al cuadrado
por la derivada con respecto a x de s
algo que en este caso ese algo es el
seno de x cuadrada así que déjame
ponerlo el seno de x cuadrada y por acá
también el seno de x cuadrada así que
sin importar que haya dentro de los
paréntesis anaranjados voy a poner eso
mismo acá abajo en los paréntesis
anaranjados de los corchetes anaranjados
y esto ya lo hemos aprendido varias
veces en los vídeos de la regla de la
cadena bien veamos hasta aquí la primera
parte de esta derivada la podemos pulir
con un poco de manipulación algebraica
pero para la segunda parte es necesario
tomar la derivada del seno de x cuadrada
y ahora observa necesitamos aplicar de
nuevo la regla de la cadena vamos a
tomar la derivada del seno de algo bueno
la derivada de esto va a ser igual al
coseno de ese algo
por la derivada con respecto a x de ese
algo y en este segundo caso ese algo es
x cuadrada y claro no olvidemos que
tenemos este de camps que es tres veces
el seno cuadrado de x cuadrada ok ya
casi llegamos al resultado ahora
necesitamos encontrar la derivada con
respecto a x de x cuadrada y lo hemos
encontrado muchas veces antes así que
simplemente usamos la regla de la
potencia y obtenemos 2x entonces 2x de
brasil
pongamos un pequeño redoble de tambor
porque si queremos saber nuestra
respuesta que es de diente x bueno ésta
va a ser igual a 3 x 2 x esto lo puedo
multiplicar me quedan 6 x los quitaré de
aquí y lo voy a poner al principio 6 x
el seno cuadrado de x cuadrada por el
coseno de x cuadrada muy bien hemos
acabado aplicamos la regla de la cadena
varias veces y así llegamos a la
respuesta hasta la próxima